bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france on va commencer par ce qui
était prévu de l'allocution du président
de la république lire les déclarations
sur les restrictions sanitaires à venir
appelle à faire vacciner les six
millions de français non vaccinés à
partir du 15 décembre validité du pass à
lithaire conditionnée à une dose de
rappel pour les plus de 65 ans et une
campagne de rappel qui sera lancée
également pour les 50 ans début décembre
écoutez
mon premier message est ainsi un appel
un appel à l'esprit de responsabilité
des six millions d'entre vous qui n'ont
encore reçu aucune dose de vex
vaccinez vous vacciner vous pour vous
protéger les personnes qui ont moins de
65 ans voit aussi la protection conférée
par le vaccin diminuer au fil du temps
d'ailleurs au moment où je vous parle
plus de 80% des personnes en réanimation
ont plus de 50 ans c'est pourquoi une
campagne de rappel sera lancée à partir
du début du mois de décembre pour nos
compatriotes
âgés de 50 à 64 ans votre réaction
franck louvrier a assez mesuré notamment
le conditionnement du dupas sanitaires
pour les plus de 65 ans à une troisième
dose
c'est une mesure qui semble totalement
efficace la seule chose c'est que le
président de la république aurait pu
nous dire sur la vérité c'est-à-dire
qu'on sait très bien ce qui va se passer
dans les semaines et les mois à venir il
suffit de regarder ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays étrangers notamment israël
on va généraliser la troisième dose
c'est à dire le rappelle donc il est
dommage qu'on soit arrêtée au milieu du
guet et qu'on n'ait pas dit totalement
la vérité aux français hier soir il
aurait pu aller plus loin le président
c'est votre avis est également une
écurie
non le président de la république
annoncé que la troisième dose serait
nécessaire pour une partie de la
population
encore une fois sur cette dose de vaccin
et parle de la population la plus à
risque les personnes de plus de 65 ans
dans les médias et des personnes
souffrant c'est donc susceptible de
comorbidité donc il s'agit aujourd'hui
comme dans la première campagne de
vaccination d'avoir un public
prioritaire avant de passer à d'autres
franges de la population
d'abord les plus de 65 ans et les + 50
ans à partir du mois de décembre ouais
mais ça a toujours été ça toujours
commencer comme ça et ça a fini
finalement à une vaccination pour pour
tous
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui les
informations elles arrivent aussi un
niveau d'information que nous avons
aujourd'hui n'est pas le même niveau
d'information que nous avions en mars
2020 donc lorsque nous avons des
éléments supplémentaires et que le
président de la république prend la
parole pour nous d'apporter des
informations supplémentaires bien
évidemment assez en fonction de l
évolution des avis scientifiques et donc
si aujourd'hui c'est les plus de 65 ans
pour la troisième dose et demain les
plus de 50 ans et bien progressivement
nous suivrons ses instructions alors on
va écouter ce que ce que disait
irrévérent justement sur cette troisième
dosée et le past anita c'était le 26
août dernier écouter
il n'y aura pas d'impact de la troisième
dose sur le pass sanitaires c'est à dire
que si vous avez votre pass sanitaire
que vous aidiez que vous alliez prendre
votre rappel ou non vous garderez le
bénéfice du pass sanitaires voilà cette
déclaration qui contredit finalement ce
qu'a dit le président hier franck
louvrier ce type de déclarations comment
comment est ce que vous prenez en fin de
compte on a un gouvernement qui tâtonne
en permanence depuis le début de cette
crise je vais pas revenir en arrière
mais on a vu ce qui s'était passé pour
les masques nous expliquer que ça
n'allait pas être imposés on nous a
expliqué que en fin de compte toutes les
mesures sanitaires qu'on a prise on
devait pas les prendre malheureusement
je trouve que la france est toujours
l'un des derniers pays à prendre les
bonnes mesures on l'a vu à chaque fois
nos pays européens ont été à
l'initiative sur cette crise sanitaire
et nous nous sommes un petit peu la
voiture balai de ces crises sanitaires
en prenant toujours au dernier moment
les décisions qu'on devrait prendre bien
en amont et c'est le cas encore hier
soir et ça a été le cas depuis ces
derniers mois c'est vraiment un
comportement assez étrange dans une
crise où il faudrait être justement
proactif essayé de créer des réponses
rapides aux situations auxquelles on est
on a vu que il fallait par exemple vite
si hydro pour le conditionnement de la
vaccination et le pas salutaire c'est la
france a été l'un des l'une des des
précurseurs en la matière l'a pourtant
en l'occurrence ils ont été l'un des
précurseurs mais ça avait déjà été pris
par d'autres pays mais surtout c'est que
pour les mesures qui concernent les
français en direct c'est à dire les
mesures de santé publique on le voit
bien on est toujours je dirais les
derniers des deux derniers à être
concernés et c'est dommage regardez hier
soir pourquoi il nous l'a dit nous le
dit pareil c'est très simple la
troisième dose sera généralisé on sait
bien on commence sur une catégorie on va
élargir la catégorie ensuite ce sera
pour l'ensemble de la population prenons
l'initiative par rapport aux données
bien évidemment médical que l'on a et
surtout à la comparaison dans les autres
pays prenons l'initiative en donnant en
disant la vérité aux français a une actu
rick justement une chose n'a pas été
évoquée par le président c'est le la
vaccination pour les 5 11 ans qui a
commencé d'ailleurs aux états unis
est-ce que ça va venir en france
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement prend des
décisions de manière progressive et
évolutif en fonction d'une de
l'évolution de l'épidémie des
informations dont nous disposons et
c'est absolument pas pour mentir aux
français que de ne vacciner aujourd'hui
de proposer une troisième dose que pour
les plus de 65 ans c'est une question de
priorité d'abord de toucher les publics
prioritaires les prix vulnérables ceux
souffrant de comorbidité et et non pas
uniquement aller sur une frange tout de
suite plus élargie et est arrivé comme
on l'a vu aujourd'hui où finalement on a
des personnes de entre 20 et 40 ans et
qui sont beaucoup plus vacciner que les
personnes de plus de 85 ans l'idéal est
là aussi elle est d'encourager le public
le plus un risque d'aller vers la
vaccination elle est là la question et
en ce qui concerne aujourd'hui la
vaccination des enfants mais
effectivement bien vu que là les états
unis avaient pris pris 7,7 cette
décision en effet on verra on va on va
on va on va parler du reste alors la
haine quand même que sur la vaccination
des enfants les enfants déjà 11
vaccination obligatoire voilà c'est dit
on verra si ça deviendra obligatoire ou
pas à l'avenir en tout cas là les
mesures sanitaires ça a pas fait la
majorité du discours d' emmanuel macron
hier à peine un tiers du temps de parole
des manuels macron qui finalement s'est
livré un bilan
de son quinquennat hier ça a été très
critiqué par l'opposition qui a dénoncé
un discours de campagne on l'a vu marine
le pen dit que cette troisième dose aura
servi d'excusé pour faire un discours de
campagne idem pour jean luc mélenchon
quand pensez-vous franck louvrier voici
une invention qui est une intervention
iceberg on a vu que la face immergée de
les choses et en fin de compte on s'est
aperçu que derrière tout ça il y avait
bien sûr un acte politique en fin de
compte c'est l'intervention de l'abandon
et de l'abandon de la mère des réformes
qui est la réforme des retraites qui
avait été promis aux français il y a
cinq ans et qui n'a pas réussi bien
évidemment à mettre en oeuvre et c'est
bien dommage parce que comme on sait ça
fait partie des priorités à la fois
économique et social de notre pays et
donc de cette larme on a vu une
intervention qui était une intervention
politique qui en fin de compte tir à la
fois un bilan et donner quelques
éléments pour le prochain quinquennat
mais la seule chose c'est qu'il faut
être réélu avant de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre les réformes qu'il a évoquée et
je crains qu'aujourd'hui le fait de
pouvoir intervenir de cette façon était
un petit peu je dirais peut perdre
permettait en fin de compte aux français
de les prendre par surprise en évoquant
soi disant que la situation sanitaire et
en faisant un discours très politique
composez vous à une lacune kuryk pardon
les français évidemment voulez savoir à
quelle sauce ils allaient être mangés
sur la crise sanitaire et ils ont le
droit à un discours assez long sur le
bilan et les réformes à venir est-ce
qu'il a eu raison de de mélanger les
genres le président hier mais le
président de la république s'adresse aux
france c'est la moindre des choses et
notamment en période certes de crise
sanitaire 1,2 rebond de l'épidémie au
que le président de la république
s'adresse aux français pour faire un
état de la situation c'est la moindre
des choses donc oui président d'un
public parle des mesures sanitaires
probable vous êtes troisième de la
troisième dose et de la situation
vaccinale et qu'il parle également
finalement en fin de mandat à quelques
mois enfin son mandat du bilan et des
réformes qui ont été faites je pense que
le quinquennat des magasins course et
surtout quinquennat des réalisations
c'est à dire des éléments
programmatiques qui ont été réalisés qui
ont été mis en oeuvre c'est le le catena
des promesses tenues certes on peut
parler de la de la réforme la réforme
des retraites n'est absolument pas
l'unique point de de preuves de
programmes qu'emmanuel macron a lancé en
2017 et aujourd'hui quand on regarde le
rythme des réformes de cuillères quatre
ans et demi le président de la
république a largement retenu un grand
nombre de ces engagements et en tout cas
de ces éléments programmatiques de
campagne de 2007 voulait agir franck
louvrier oui non franchement on le voit
bien l'attitude et l'intervention d'hier
c'est la neuvième comme je vous le
rappelle de façon unilatérale c'est à
dire sans en plus vous permettrait
d'apporter cet élément-là sur la forme
sans contradiction une contre adducteurs
c'est quand même assez étonnant lorsque
l'on n'intervient par surprise sur des
sujets politiques ont au moins on
autorise d'avoir une contradiction que
ce soit d'un journaliste où d'un échange
qui puisse être débattu là aujourd'hui
on est dans une situation en fin de
compte on reçoit un message qui est un
message électoral qui n'est pas du tout
un message à des fins sanitaires ou à
des fins de politique intérieure
et justement je pense que là vraiment
c'est une erreur parce que c'est
toujours délicat de prendre en otages
les français sur une émission de
télévision vous le savez c'est un parent
c'est un rendez vous essentiel on ne
peut pas se permettre de l'utiliser
comme une page de publicité politique
jamais il n'y a absolument pas de prise
d'otages il s'agit de l'allocution du
président de la cub qui nous fait état
d'une situation exceptionnelle et qui
met en avant aussi des mesures qui ont
été prises enfin un moment donné il faut
aussi le rappeler à dire que on parle
beaucoup et effectivement dupas
sanitaires on parle beaucoup de la
troisième dose de vaccin mais enfin et
quand on regarde la stratégie globale
qui a été celle du gouvernement et du
président de la république par toute
cette crise elle dépasse juste le simple
sujet de dupas sanitaire ou de la
vaccination c'est aussi la prise en
charge des salariés avec le chômage pas
la mise en oeuvre du chômage partiel
avec la mise en place du fonds de
solidarité avec les pêcheurs qui par
ailleurs sont prolongés jusqu'en juin
2022 c'est tout c'est tout ce que ce
plan de relance qui a permis aussi de
réagir suite au rebond en fin de période
d'épidémie ce plan de relance justement
qui nous pousse à ouvrir vers d'autres
sur d'autres sujets mais parce que cette
crise sanitaire est là elle a fait quoi
elle a exacerbé des réalités des
réalités sur notre manque d'indépendance
énergétique sur les difficultés
aujourd'hui d'approvisionnement de
matières premières mais toute cette
stratégie là global elle doit partager
avec les français les âges ni des
ouvrages et
la présidentielle est expliquée à six
mois des élections présidentielles qu'il
faut des centrales nucléaires
supplémentaires alors que en début de
mandat vous avez fait alliance notamment
avec un ministre qui était anti
nucléaire c'est vraiment dans la
contradiction totale par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé il ya quelques mois donc
je veux bien croire que le réveil est
tardif mais le réveil il est plutôt
électorale que tardif dans des
situations pareilles on ne peut pas se
fiche de la tête des français et on doit
les respecter et je suis désolé dans une
période électorale maintenant dans
laquelle on rentre il faut assumer des
responsabilités et là on voit bien que
le bilan n'est pas la hauteur des
promesses c'est vrai que avait prévu de
fermer 14 réacteurs nucléaires dont 4
avant 2025 pourquoi ce revirement à une
amérique parce que les raisons parlé la
veille les lors du débat
il y a eu il y a eu le premier combat
sur la fermeture des centrales à charbon
ça ça a été un engagement fort qui a été
pris et ensuite aujourd'hui quand on
regarde l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie quand on regarde et par
ailleurs le gouvernement prend ses
responsabilités avec le gel des prix de
l'électricité et du gaz et quand on voit
que c'est finalement là on a une
meilleure maîtrise là on produit nous
mêmes l'énergie c'est à dire
l'électricité et grâce au nucléaire eh
bien il faut qu'on prenne ddf et il
mesure en conséquence et donc pour moi
aujourd'hui continuer à développer les
énergies renouvelables comme le plan
photovoltaïque avec les mille projets
qui ont été annoncées est apprécié de la
république et la ministre de la
transition écologique seront des bonnes
mesures mais qui ne doivent pas être en
opposition avec finalement notre
souveraineté énergétique qui se fait
grâce au nucléaire aujourd'hui on compte
j'ai l'impression que ce gouvernement
apprend en avançant malheureusement ce
qu'on demande à un chef de l'état c'est
de se projeter dans l'avenir et je vous
rappelle quand même que quand on écoute
et quand on revoit tout ce qui a été dit
au début de ce quinquennat sur la
politique énergétique allaient
totalement contradictoire avec ce qu'on
nous annonce hier soir vous le voyez je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut être
face à aux réalités mais surtout c'est
qu'on demande à des élus c'est de
pouvoir avoir un peu d'expérience et de
pouvoir se projeter dans l'avenir et les
centrales nucléaires et le nucléaire
était utile dans le mix énergétique
malheureusement il a fallu faire
alliance au début de ce gouvernement
avec la gauche et donc de ce fait là
vous êtes retrouvé prisonnier de vos
positions et maintenant vous déménagez
de faire machine arrière l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre
oui mais c'est parce que vous avez
défendu au début du quinquennat va
l'affronter ça va depuis la gestion est
en contradiction
antinucléaires
suis désolé mais les positions de
nicolas hulot n'était pas tellement en
faveur du nucléaire il a même manifesté
pendant des années contre le nucléaire
donc vous savez je veux bien le croire
mais ce qui compte c'est quand même
l'incarnation des hommes et des femmes
qui dirigent ce gouvernement est à part
monsieur macron je vois pas qui
aujourd'hui prend la position qui ont
été prises il ya quelques temps franck
louvrier alors ce discours est prononcé
au lendemain du débat les républicains
où il ya eu évidemment une grande prise
de position aussi pour la construction
de nouvelles centrales nucléaires
est ce que pour vous ce choix de faire
un discours un peu bilan est justement
lié au fait qu'il y avait ce débat les
républicains et en fait aussi que eric
zemmour est un candidat non déclaré qui
montrent aussi dans les sondages c'est
le point commun avec monsieur macron
c'est que ce sont 2 candidat non déclaré
et qui n'assume pas en fin de compte
leur programme et leurs projections dans
les mois à venir non au delà de ça on le
voit bien monsieur macro été élu en
partie grâce à la gauche comme président
de la république est un peu avec des
électeurs de droite aujourd'hui il a
perdu toute la gauche et ils essayent de
récupérer quelques électeurs de droite
parce qu'ils voient que la droite
s'organise la droite peut avoir un
candidat qui est susceptible de
l'affronter et de gagner et donc de ce
fait là cette opération médiatique
d'hier soir est arrivé comme par hasard
au lendemain du premier débat de des
républicains pour écouter ça ça fait
partie je dirais de la guerre médiatique
la seule chose c'est que au fond des
choses on ne peut pas percevoir que son
programme est celui qui a été prévu il y
a quelques mois et qui est en fin de
compte vraiment en termes de
propositions des choses qui sont
totalement je dirais prix ou dans le
programme de la droite ou qui était en
contradiction avec ce qu'il avait dit à
quelques mois et on le voit bien comme
par hasard on comprend des mesures sur
le travail franchement je pense qu'il
faut pas prendre les électeurs pour des
gens naïfs il faut assumer ce qui n a
pas été fait et ce qui peut être fait et
de ce fait là ne pas essayer de picorer
dans l'ensemble des programmes pour
essayer de se refaire une virginité ou
simplement c'est que les manuels mâcon
n'a pas attendu la droite pour réformer
le travail là leur travail est arrivé en
tout début de ce quinquennat et sur
l'assurance chômage c'est une mise en
oeuvre d'une réforme qui a été retardée
de puis 18 mois justement au regard de
la situation sanitaire et je pense que
quand on regarde le résultat notamment
la baisse du chômage à la baisse du taux
de chômage aujourd'hui en france à 7,6
pour cent quand on voit que le chômage
des jeunes n'a jamais été aussi bas
depuis 15 ans qu'on ne peut pas dire de
la crise et donc du lendemain de la
crise de 2008 où le chômage au taux de
chômage était à 25% et là on est à 7,6
pour cent de taux de chômage quand on
voit finalement l'accompagnement dans le
travail avec l'apprentissage qui monte
en puissance avec les accompagnements
aussi pour que les entreprises puissent
recruter les jeunes avec les aides de
4000 à 8000 euros pour les jeunes de
moins de 25 ans je pense que nous
n'avons pas attendu la droite pour
promouvoir le travail et pour permettre
que le travail coûte moins cher c'est ce
qui est fait depuis quatre ans et demi
par cette majorité et emmanuel macron
n'a pas besoin d'aller chercher ni à
droite ni à gauche l'élargissement il a
été alors il a été annoncé depuis 2010
est où on est peut-être ni de droite ni
de gauche et de droite et de gauche mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas un candidat
qui a quitté un parti politique pour
reprendre une carte et se présenter aux
primaires chez les républicains comme le
fait que guy bertrand aujourd'hui voilà
c'est si on a tellement bien
malheureusement est proche du parti
socialiste et moi ribbon donc si on veut
faire ce débat qui était un peu je lui
dirai pas tellement de du niveau de ce
que je souhaiterais mais en tout cas
c'est pas c'est pas le cas non on n'a
pas de gens malheureux s'en sont
ouvriers je suis désolé je suis désolé
on va laisser le mot de la fin à une
incurie c'est la fin de ce débat de la
matinale